let's go to the 704 area code caller
from 704 tell us who you are and you can
jump right into your question hey David
this is Brian hood does know from
Charlotte North Carolina see it's so
good to talk to you man I've called in a
couple of times and actually like
probably it doesn't right Wow well I'm
glad you got through the phone lines get
very very icy bright I'm so excited
about this okay so David look my
question is what do you think it's going
to take what do you think it's gonna be
what has to take place what will be the
elements of our country that kind of
like you say sort of list the country
out of our current and zeitgeist right
what will it be that gets people to
realize oh oh wow like look it isn't
yeah I guess right now we do want to
pass marijuana laws and yeah I guess
right now we do want equality for
certain people and certain yeah we do
want to house our veteran wallet II
would be for every but above all else
yeah yeah yeah above all else we want to
get some money out of politics we have
to get the money out of politics
politics we absolutely have to and so
that is something that it's tuns me that
there are people who don't think that
that is in fact the issue that is the
root of all of our problems in this
country some would say climate change
but what is so Brian what's your
question tonight what will it be
what will it be that gets people to
understand that what would it be
something would it be a politician would
it be a social agent would it be a
culture something in the culture would
it be a film a song of an artist well
like what will it take to get people to
understand what that money needs to be
gotten out of politics right yeah yeah
and sort of just kind of and sort of
lift us out of a culture of people in
this country that are so that they don't
got it I think they're very apathetic of
political culture does that make sense
because it makes some sells and I'll do
the best I can with it yes so Brian okay
I think that the issue here is that
fundamentally money in politics is not
like a sexy issue it's also not an issue
that has like a discrete beginning and
end so the that makes it not a good
story for corporate media which is where
a lot of people get get their news so if
I had the answer to what will make the
issue of money in politics mainstream
I'd already be working and activating
around it there are different groups
that are working on trying to pass at
the state level rules around money in
politics there's attempts to repeal
citizens united although there's debate
and disagreement as to whether that's
that's sort of the best path forward so
I don't have the answer but where I do
agree with you in the interest of trying
to find some common ground I do agree
with you that whatever issue you care
about like whether it's the environment
or abortion or net neutrality or
whatever the sort of overarching issues
are media coverage of what matters to
you and how politics is financed which
basically dictates everything about
every political issue at this point so I
think at least you and I seem to agree
that it is it is basically the meta
issue around all political issues right
now mm-hmm
and you know it when that gets out when
when you have when you basically
dislodge the biggest memes of corruption
that keeps the entire system back yeah I
think the overall faith of the people in
this country decades down the line will
be that there will be very enthusiastic
to participate in political discussions
well and they don't take issue I hope
that the interest in fixing the system
is what would actually get people
interested rather than it being
something that people get involved once
we fix money in politics I think it
would be better to get people involved
now in order to fix it Brian I
appreciate the call very very important
issue